[Musique]
instant solennel ce jeudi 23 juin au
palais de la source pour le département
élire cèpes ou y l'institut réunionnais
des services de proximité de l'océan
indien ce centre de formation
d'apprentis créé sous l'impulsion du
conseil départemental est opérationnel
depuis juillet 2021 a tenu à mettre à
l'honneur sa première promotion ils
étaient quarante cinq récipiendaires
quarante quatre femmes et un homme à
recevoir leur diplôme d'intervenants
d'hygiène de vie à domicile l'occasion
pour le département de félicité les
diplômés ce matin nous étions réunis
pour remettre les premiers diplômes aux
premières promotions dans cette salle
même c'est une grande fierté pour le
département d'ailleurs on félicite
l'ensemble des diplômés qui se sont
engagés dans un parcours important et
nous ne doutons pas peu à l'avenir nous
aurons d'autres personnes qui vont
suivre cette voie dans sept secteurs où
il ya des besoins l'emploi une première
année de formation qui a donné des
résultats très encourageants et
notamment concernant l'insertion
professionnelle des bénéficiaires
un bilan très positif on a démarré
quatre groupes en fin d'année dernière
et ils ont terminé récemment fin mai et
on a un taux de réussite de 90 7% et en
notebook est très satisfaisant qui l
employabilité à moins d'un mois de fin
de l'information nous sommes à 52 %
d'employabilité beaucoup ont commencé
par des remplacements donc des essais et
là encore hier et tous les jours on
apprend qu effectivement ça se
concrétise par des cdi par du temps
plein parce qu'il ya véritablement de la
demande les services à la personne un
métier d'avenir qui offre de belles
perspectives d'insertion comme ce fut le
cas pour christine je m'occupe déjà
d'une personne âgée et je me suis dit
pourquoi pas en faire mon métier
justement par rapport à tout ça et je
fais des gestes peut-être qu'ils soient
pas
conforme que ça pour marc pour être donc
c'est pour ça j'ai au niveau du pôle
emploi pour pouvoir m'orienter effet
alors qu'à m'embêter donc j'ai suivi une
formation avec la sep on a eu un job
dating au mois de mai et au 2 juin mais
maintenant je travaille avec déjà seul
homme de sa promotion philippe a tenu à
lancer un appel à ceux qui hésiteraient
encore à sauter le pas je lance un appel
parce que je pense que c'est aujourd'hui
on est dans la mixité ça veut dire que
c'est pas fermée pour pour les hommes il
ya bien des aides soignants qui sont
sommes comme des aides soignants qui
sont femmes lorsqu'il fait je pense que
c'est un métier pour tout le monde il ya
là domaniale du travail dans ce
métier-là 17 formations assez fait pour
trouver un
chômage c'était costaud
on l'a eu la cérémonie s'est clôturée ce
jeudi dans une atmosphère conviviale
mélange de joie d'émotion et de fierté
pour les nouveaux diplômés
[Musique]